also wie eingerückt sind zu fünft war es
schon so dass wir frauen
zusammengehalten haben weil wir einfach
anders waren exoten waren in der kaserne
mit der grundausbildung hat man dann die
anderen kameraden kennen gelernt und
sich dann der eigenen gruppen gesucht
eigentlich hat aber genug unterstützung
auch von den anderen kameraden bekommen
der erste tag war eigentlich abenteuer
wir haben das ganze mal ausprobiert und
die die burschen seines tag später rückt
somit haben eigentlich eine pizza kommt
und es war so angespannt im moment bin
ich in der öffentlichkeitsarbeit das
habe ich kennengelernt und das hat mich
interessiert und ich bin eigentlich
jetzt so ein bisschen rhein gekippt
wir betreuen homepage zeitung und andere
medien sehr viel presse aber regionale
pressearbeit und ich bin davon überzeugt
dass frauen in dieser position den
berührungsängsten der zivilisten
entgegen wirken
es ist selbstverständlich ein profi so
den eindruck
also ich habe vorher mit den eltern
gesprochen für dsds jusos
selbstverständlich dass der damen wc es
gibt dass da irgendwo getrennt wird
das ordnungs wunde
also in unserer kompanie ist zwar frauen
und wir verstehen uns recht gut
miteinander und die die burschen die
akzeptieren unser als es überhaupt kein
problem
die zusammenarbeit für uns ist er kein
unterschied war nachrücken
mit uns mit sport macht also komplett
normale situation es ist anstrengend
aber machbar
dadurch dass wir auch in
leistungsgruppen eingeteilt sind und
beweist einkommen die mit ihren dabei in
dieser gruppe sind haben ungefähr deine
fähigkeiten wenn du schwach bildlichen
schwächer dann schauen sie dass du
aufgebaut wirst und natürlich mit einer
guten leistungsgruppe bis dahin sie
einfach schauen dass du noch besser
wirst für niemals körperliche oder
anziehen um es ehrlich gesagt ich bin
anna jäger komponieren wir waren nur
diffus und das war für mich ziemlich
anstrengend ich sehe gerade pioniere
jetzt als eine sehr sinnvolle tätigkeit
die man gebrauchen kann
im ausland jetzt haben wir sechs folgt
ihnen die frauen machen einen tollen job
und ich sehe überhaupt keine probleme
hier den art und weise im zusammenleben
im dienstbetrieb wichtig ist dass die
aufgabe erfüllt wird und die wird
perfekt erfüllt und damit bin ich schon
zufrieden
ihr habt zwar kinder und das ist für
mich natürlich an erster stelle wir
haben gleichzeitig bin teilzeit
beschäftigt und für mich erkennt man die
show vorstellen ins ausland zu gehen
weil sie doch neue erfahrungen ganz
besonderes wieder als in österreich
ich war 2010 für sechs monate im kosovo
mit einem multinationalen team von
schweizern türken und deutschen und es
war sich eine großartige erfahrung und
mein privates umfeld hat mich irrsinnig
unterstützt von einem auslandseinsatz
dadurch dass ich ein kind schon habe war
das auch nicht so einfach für mich ist
aber schon in erwägung dass ich noch
einmal gehe allerdings muss es mein sohn
amtlichen größer werden